[Musik]
hallöchen lieben heute gibt es einen
grund rezepte machen richtig köstliches
creme brulée haben sagt mal creme leben
sagte brüderle
ich weiß das ist ein sehr einfaches wort
es ist ein französisches wort und das
ist eigentlich so eine art vanille
dessert vanillepudding kann man schon
sagen mit seiner flambierten zucker
haube obendrauf man serviert das halt
kalt aber die zucker haube die dann
karamellisiert wird mit dem schlamm
ihrer die ist wiederum war also richtig
köstlich mein rezept heute besteht aus
nur eins zwei drei vier aus vier zutaten
also richtig super überschaubar und was
ich auch mache dass ich jetzt gerade
überlegt ich benutze mein schneebesen
ich bis heute keine maschinen ihr könnt
es alles wunderbar nachmachen selbst
ohne handrührgerät oder küchenmaschine
sondern dass wir sind die zutaten die
wir benötigen
das ist einmal zucker ganz gewöhnlicher
haushaltszucker
dann haben wir hier schlag sahne eier
jedoch brauchen wir hier nur das eigelb
und vanille extrakt alternativ könnt ihr
auch eine vanilleschote verwenden
jetzt schnappt ihr euch eine ausreichend
große schüssel da muss später auch noch
die sahne reinpassen die sahne wird aber
später noch einmal separat erhitzt und
ich gebe jetzt in die schüssel eigelb
zucker und vanille extra kinos röhrig
das drei bis vier minuten lang richtig
schön dick cremig und das mache ich
jetzt heute wie gesagt mit einem
schneebesen
[Musik]
so muss die ergebnisse nach drei minuten
aussehen und dann gehen wir auch schon
die schlagsahne in dem topf und erhitzen
dass zum beispiel bei stufe 6 von 9 so
mache ich das und er ist es einfach so
lange bis kleine bläschen entstehen und
nicht weiter sie darf nicht auf koch in
die saane und die geben wir jetzt ist es
nimmt die perfekte temperatur nach und
nach zurück masse und unter ständigem
rühren einarbeiten und es ist wichtig
dass er da wirklich immer nur
stückchenweise dazu gibt und haben sich
bräuchte jetzt auch am liebsten deine
hilfe
dann kannst du nämlich stückchenweise
dazugeben und ich früher so machen was
kampf ist nein das packst du ja nur ein
stückchen ok stoppel bin ich gut super
[Musik]
wunderbar hamza 100 punkte danke für
deine hilfe
wie kriegst natürlich auch ohne einander
zu hause hin also einfach und fleißig
höhen während ihre augen ist es ein
bisschen schwieriger nein das rezept ist
wirklich total easy ich habe jetzt auch
die ganze masse her mal ungefüllt dann
will ich das gleich ganz einfach in die
feuerfesten förmchen füllen kann
die habe ich hier schon bereit und legt
die auch auf jeden fall entweder in ein
tiefes backblech oder in eine
auflaufform weil gleich kommt noch der
konsistenz wegen heißes wasser in die
auflaufform ich habe sich hier auch
immer wieder bei kaufman eingekauft weil
es ist noch nicht gemerkt habt und
neuerdings kaufe ich ganz klar die
schlagsahne in diesem wieder
verschließbaren behältern ich finde es
einfach praktisch und das rezept ist
auch auf 500 gramm sahne hochgerechnet
und ich schreibe euch sowieso alles in
die video beschreibung was ihr benötigt
so und jetzt gebe ich einfach die masse
in die förmchen und die dürfte auch fast
ganz bis oben hin voll machen
später kommt nämlich eine ganz dünne
schicht zucker drauf
[Musik]
sollte habe ich wie gesagt die auch für
form noch mal halb voll mit kochendem
wasser bedeckt und jetzt kommen unsere
creme brulée es in den vorgeheizten
backofen ganz wichtig dass die ihm
vorgehalten auf 150 grad ober unterhitze
dann brauchen sie so ungefähr 55 bis 60
minuten und anschließend mindestens
zweieinhalb bis drei stunden auskühlen
lassen und dann kommt erst die schöne
zucker kruste obendrauf und deshalb
sehen wir uns eventuell sogar morgen
erst wieder ich lasse sie nämlich dann
auch gerne über nacht aus können also
bis dann
[Musik]
jetzt durfte mein creme brulée über
nacht einmal komplett auskühlen ich hab
es auch im kühlschrank gelagert und
jetzt sind sie bereit für die karamell
kruste obendrauf und dafür nehmt ihr
euch jetzt den haushaltszucker und
streut so ein bisschen auf die
oberfläche und dann flambieren wir das
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr das noch dekorieren wie
ihr möchtet ich finde immer das grüne
total gut dazu passen
je nachdem was für eine saison wir haben
auch gerne früchte und jetzt hört ihr
diese kruste einfach nur köstlich jetzt
schon mit dem löffel rhein werden wir
oben diese karamell kruste und unten
darf dann ganz weich sein perfekt
perfekt genau so muss es sein
und jetzt könnt ihr das zum beispiel zu
einem gänge menü servieren das wäre dann
so das dessert oder einfach mal als
überraschung für jemanden den ich gerne
habt und ich können wir das jetzt in
aller ruhe und wünsche euch ganz viel
freude beim nachbacken vergesst nicht
dem video einen deutschen nach oben zu
geben mich kostenlos zu abonnieren
einfach passt ihr solch geniale rezepte
auch nicht und ansonsten können wir in
den kommentaren und gerne miteinander
schreiben bis zum nächsten mal auf die
skizzenbücher bis zu einer hand fragen
ist es wirklich so toll ich vergesse
nicht dir zu teilen
[Musik]